welcome to this video playing Penelope
Cruz okay saludos from 10-11 okay ah
interesting let's see what happens i'm
going to transpose to the sicilian oh
it's interesting to try people sometimes
play not f3c five and don't really have
anything in the sicilian okay as
sidelined with g3 i can probably know
why i need to play this first okay yeah
that this is an interesting line it's
getting some slight popularity in recent
times getting white quite a good
development and probably some play
against the isolated pawn in the long
run ok let's take then maybe Bishop g5
okay so interesting he does not
recapture me at least so I'm going to
try to keep it why not Knight g4 I've
got Bishop g4
oh interesting
hmm yeah that's interesting it somewhat
hampers my development this Knight c3 is
not really a hmm maybe Knight c3 I can
take on c3 and just tripled my pawns
it's not as bad as it seems to be at
first but yeah I don't like it let's
just play it play it a simple way at
least them this way I'm speeding up my
development a bit the night wants to be
on b3 anyway to cover deform ok so I
have a nice locating position against
the isolated pawn and black does not
have any great activity so this position
should be m at least slightly more
comfortable for white yep that's a five
is a very normal way to play this
isolated Queen pong trying to disturb me
with a form so i need to play it for
myself the drawback is of course that
black has weakened to the b5 square and
the whole Queen side but normally you
are sort of accept this as a trade of
other activity that you get my idea here
is to if possible play the night to be
five and then maybe night c5a activating
those those nights
yeah nights if I force the idea all the
way now I'm attacking a4 b7 and possibly
60 this looks like a good move and
trading off the e4 night cannot be a bad
thing so this has nothing to fear mm gel
94 hmm yeah like it's still fairly solid
and active I cannot white cannot claim
any em any antigen ever Tate him with 97
and taking a five let's see rupee one
next yeah at least I have a good
blockade against the depot okay let's
see the bishop on b6 is also played
there because I thought that maybe 95 is
one of the ideas and then i can probably
take a five but even that is not so
clear 95 bishop a five-night c4 it's not
not bad okay
yeah I don't really know maybe I I need
to do that at some point Knight takes c6
Bishop a five maybe this imitates her
okay so we get some traits and I see
that he has got Roxy for maybe at the
end of all that that's fairly actor
phone yeah okay if he takes a for now I
have Bishop g5 at the end okay so okay
maybe this is not so great but still I
can take him I cannot take him he ate is
protected well I have a very nice
miscalculation okay okay then I'll just
take p7 funny this is this could have
gone terribly wrong okay so um ship c6
speaking of some things going terribly
wrong thank you just a blunder the rogue
black resides yeah every don't think
that was was much going on black seems
active enough yeah what what seems to
still have a slight edge due to the comp
according to the kabuki aid group f aid
weird ok white is slightly better it
seems around here I also thought that
what should have little something and
yeah maybe 94 immediately was was easier
here the computer wants to do F
this is a move I really cannot believe
in it seems very weakening I'll care
there's d for maybe the a black is far
too active here with whites open King I
don't like that yeah i think it was okay
i played this at least it should
preserve a little little edge so you
know Peters also look a eight just
covering all that and keeping the
subject does not seem to be bad yeah
black has enough activity problem the
way you played it he just needs to avoid
this this thing and play em a normal
move let's say I'm up to eight and I
mean what why does a bit better but
nothing much okay thanks for watching